Eric Adams then said we are a sanctuary
City so all sorts of people started
coming from all parts of the world they
would get through our poorest border
they'd show up in New York City and they
have turned New York City into a
disgusting crime-infested pot smelling
sewage-filled crap Factory
I did that with no teleprompter okay
people this is all just coming out of my
brain well then what happens it happens
for a long enough all your productive
people they start leaving your city your
city is a dump and then you start
realizing that we can't handle all of
these people in our Sanctuary City and
we don't want them anymore Eric Adams
our cities are being undermined and we
don't deserve this
migrants don't deserve this
and the people who live in the cities
don't deserve this we expect more from
our national leaders to address this
issue in a real way we learned today
which is very informative and that's why
it was important to come here
that there are websites that are
advertising that New York City basically
speaks a day with gold that this
automatic employment that you
automatically want to be living in hotel
there's a conversation among those who
are Asylum and mindful Asylum Seekers
and migrants who are getting given the
false impression that when you come to
New York City everything is fine
Eric Eric you were the one that called
for New York City to be a sanctuary City
you were the one that said hey come here
you're the one that actually tried to
get some of the illegal immigrants to
vote in elections which would have been
doubly illegal
uh you also support the president of the
United States and the Democrat Party who
are in charge of the Border they're the
ones in charge right now but what
happens all of your stupid Lefty ideas
come to your door all of the good people
leave your city your city crumbles and
now it's a problem now it is a problem
so how is it guys that they are able to
get everything wrong always
foreign
[Music]